welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar the future of the
cannabis supply chain presented by
Benjamin Sher Ali founder and chief
executive officer
silly Bray my name is xavier gutierrez
and i would be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars now before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to attain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Benjamin sure le
I will now turn the presentation over to
him hi everybody great to be with you
here today and appreciate you taking the
time to hear about the cannabis supply
chain so before we get into exactly what
the talk is today it's a pretty exciting
time to be alive it's not very often
that an industry comes online out of
prohibition or otherwise that is this
massive and this large and does so in
parallel with a bunch of really cool
tech getting invented and implemented
across industries and this table here
represents a bunch of the technologies
that we see being employed across a
bunch of industries today and I'm here
to tell you that the technology that is
going to be most consequential not only
for cannabis but globally is actually
this desk plant and more specifically
the cells within that plant biology is
nothing short of the world's most
sophisticated manufacturing technology
every cell on the planet has machines
and those machines are instructed by DNA
code to take nutrients and turn them
into stuff and they can do so
sustainably in its scale but why doesn't
why does this matter
it matters because first cells copy
themselves this means once you have a
cell that can make a product it
duplicates itself the way to think about
this is if you're making an iPhone and
you've noticed some water on the iPhone
and the iPhone just replicated itself
that's what we're talking about here you
have a cell that makes a product and
then it makes copies of itself over and
over and over again
cells also repair themselves so when
cells are manufacturing products if
something goes wrong they have internal
mechanisms to go ahead and fix those
issues this means less downtime lower
maintenance costs and more continuous
production cells are also extremely
precise if you think about why cells are
manufacturing products for the most part
they're doing it to survive and when
you're doing something for survival you
want to be very very precise so when a
cell is making a product it does so with
really really extreme accuracy and
lastly cells are a sustainable way to
produce products by definition they're
living organisms so if they created
toxic byproducts they would kill
themselves and stop producing those
toxic byproducts so by definition they
are sustainable what's where is this
very very apparent as cells as the
manufacturing technology well believe it
or not
cannabis is actually a great example of
this if you go to the 30,000 foot level
and say what what is cannabis actually
doing in one of those cells doing it's
taking nutrients from the soil water and
sunlight and simultaneously
manufacturing over 400 chemicals a
hundred of which are bioactive think
about that if you ask Pfizer or Dow jump
on tour archers Daniel Midland or any of
these big ingredient pharmaceutical or
chemical producers to do that type of
production with accuracy and consistency
they wouldn't know where to begin with
their technologies but biology can do it
simply easily
and reproducibly so what we're going to
be talking about today in the cannabis
supply chain is actually not cannabis or
the plant itself and what's known as
flower products or the actual plant
biomass what we're going to be talking
about is changing the way that we
produce the extracted materials or more
specifically the bioactive materials
known as cannabinoids it's maybe a
pretty controversial statement but
cannabis is not medicine what's actually
medicine are these small bioactive
molecules found within the plant known
as cannabinoids the most popular and
well-known of those is CBD and THC CBD
is the non psychoactive molecule that is
used in a bunch of different products
and was recently approved by GW Pharma
for the treatment of epileptic seizures
THC is the psychoactive component of the
plant the the part that causes the
euphoric effect or what's known as the
high so before we get into house two
Libre is going to hack the supply chain
let's first talk about how these
extracts are made today so if you want
to make a cannabis extract you first
start with your input and in this case
the input is a plant there are a lot of
people doing things around genetics of
the plant and breeding the plant to make
the concentration of those chemicals hit
certain specifications so in other words
if you want more THC you've read or you
genetically modify or you clone a plant
that makes high concentrations of THC
once you have your input or your seeds
or your plant that you want to start
with you then grow those plants up this
is usually a three to six month
procedure like you would any plant you
grow it in an agricultural field and
then you go ahead and you cultivate
those plants and you take and you
harvest them once you harvest the
planets you then have to extract the
cannabinoids from them and this has done
a variety of methods the most the most
sophisticated of which is probably
supercritical co2 but there are a bunch
of different technologies being
developed for extractions and what you
end up extracting is a collection of
chemicals remember I said this plant
makes over 400 chemicals simultaneously
so when you extract those chemicals you
extract whatever the plant decided to
make there
there are a bunch of different variables
to control the the end result but what
you end up with is a collection of kind
of those 400 chemicals in some
combination and concentrations of each
if you want to get down to the isolate
form and by isolate form I mean just a
single molecule so let's say you just
want CBD you start with an input of a
plant usually for CBD is hemp not
cannabis that has high concentrations of
t/l CBD you go through this entire
process and then at the end when you're
trying to get down to just CBD and
you're doing your additional
purification steps to do so you have
less work to do if you wanted to make
THC you actually have to start this
entire process back over at the
beginning and start with an input that
has a high concentration of THC
unfortunately today getting any of the
molecules below that in there isolate
form or in their specific ingredient
form is almost impossible and for those
where it is possible it's prohibitively
expensive very very expensive and that's
just the nature of the fact that the
plant makes those molecules in very very
low quantities so remember back in the
beginning of the presentation I said
biology is nothing short of the world's
most sophisticated manufacturing
technology so what have I told you that
we could treat cells
like that we could treat them like
factories remember every cell has
machines those machines are instructed
by DNA code to turn nutrients into stuff
well we now do have that ability we can
actually go into cells pop out the
machinery that they have naturally put
in new machinery and rewrite their DNA
code to turn them into manufacturing
facilities for almost a limitless number
of products from textiles to medicines
and beyond one example of this that will
probably resonate with people and hit
home is insulin production if you know
anybody that's diabetic and has taken
insulin we used to get insulin from a
very unsustainable unsalable scaleable
source and that is the pig pancreas we
used to actually take insulin from a pig
pancreas today we don't use pigs at all
pigs have been completely removed from
the supply chain and that's because a
very smart scientist
my Lily said we'll wait a second I could
change the machinery and reprogram an e
coli cell to make the same exact insulin
that we're getting from a pig pancreas
and today that is how we make our
medicines so whatever we took this same
concept and we did it in cannabis well
it turns out we can and what we're doing
it so Libre is we have identified three
different cell lines that we can
actually take the machinery pop it out
pop in new machinery and use those cells
to in a fermentation process like beer
make cannabis extracts here's how this
works
I don't want to get too deep into the
science but what you see on the slide
now is actually the representation of a
cell and this shows the blueprint for
what we are going to engineer into our
three different cells to start producing
cannabis extracts the input here instead
of plants and having to grow those
plants over time is sugar water the cell
will consume that sugar word of water
and metabolize it into these different
pathways starting with acetyl co a
acetyl co a will then go down two
different paths to eventually produce
GPP and to leave it taluk acid those two
chemicals will then be combined to
create CB GA and from CB GA we can then
create all of the cannabinoids CBC CBD
THC and we will have a cell that
produces those this is how we do the
engineering there are about 17
potentially more different chemical
reactions that we have to engineer in
here each one of those chemical
reactions done with an enzyme or a
machine and eventually we will be able
to go from these very cheap inputs of
sugar water and produce these molecules
so how will they actually produce a
great been you have a cell that you've
changed machinery and rewritten DNA code
for how does this actually work what
works a lot like a brewery any brewery
that you've ever been in so once we have
these cells that make CBD our inputs
instead of plants become our cells put
into a fermentation tank and fed sugar
water we then ferment those like you
would beer but instead of beer
what is
is what we've programmed those cells to
make in this case CBD what if we want to
make THC do we run into the same
problems that we ran into with
agriculture the answer to that is no we
can use the same equipment the same
downstream processing we just changed
the inputs and actually we only change
one of the inputs instead of using our
CBD cells we would use our THC cells the
blue sugar water ferment them and you're
off to the races making pure natural THC
one of the two big push backs I get on
this from a lot of people in industry or
one people will immediately say well
then you're making synthetic THC that is
not the case the way to think about this
is that we are making the same natural
product just using a different cell
factory instead of a so slow growth very
complicated very variable cell like a
cannabis plant we are using very
simplified programmed cells like yeast
or or other types of types of cell lines
the second one I get is well Ben is a
GMO because you're doing gene editing in
these cells we'll remember what we're
making is the chemical it's CBD its THC
at CBN at CBC those are chemicals
chemicals don't have DNA so by
definition something that doesn't have
DNA cannot be genetically modified what
we're genetically modifying is the
manufacturing facility not the actual
consumer product so that's that's that's
the way to think about those two things
in the context of the broader cannabis
space so one of the implications of this
for the industry well once we have this
technology working and it's
commercialized there are a couple really
clear advantages first is the
sustainability of production if you
think about what's going on today in
cannabis and there was actually a really
interesting study done in 2017 about
energy use as an example if you were to
take a 5 million square foot greenhouse
and use a hundred percent of that flower
for extract when it comes to scaling our
technology we would be able to do that
same volume and in and around 20
thousand square feet this is a really
good proxy for
source usage and sustainability that
2017 study I mentioned actually took at
the end took a look at the energy use
just as one variable in the cannabis
industry and what they found is that in
2016 the US cannabis industry used six
billion dollars of energy just to put
that in context we're talking about an
industry that's under prohibition has
not scaled is done state to state and
really doesn't have any volume compared
to what the ultimate market will be also
to put that number in perspective the
entire pharmaceutical industry in the
u.s. used just over 1 billion dollars of
energy so cannabis before it even scales
before prohibition has been ended before
it goes global is already 6x the u.s.
pharmaceutical industry in energy usage
we think this is a really really
important point I think today when
you're dealing with consumer products
medicines it really any product you not
only need to think about the quality of
the product and and the product market
fit but you also need to think about
when this scales are we actually being
harmful or helpful to the planet so I
think what we're trying to do here is
say look there's a better more
sustainable way that to make these
products in the long run and quite
frankly in the short run as well the
next one is an economic question the
plant and the beauty of the plant is
that it has this really elegant ability
to manufacture 400 chemicals
simultaneously but because it has 400
chemicals in it the concentrations of
those chemicals differ and the
concentration of those chemicals is
ultimately what drives the plant
economics so we have a graph here and to
give kudos I stole this graph from
Michael at Kronos and Jason Kelly at
ginkgo they gave this in their in their
speech they they also are working on
this science and and what this graph
really shows is the cost of a purified
cannabinoid per kilogram on the y-axis
and on the x-axis is the cannabinoid
content by percent biomass so how much
of the of the total plant biomass is
actually cannabinoid and what you see
here is that for things like THC and CBD
which are kind of on the long tail here
of percent can now
content by biomass you're at around
7,500 to $15,000 and costs to actually
extract these chemicals from the plant
but if you want any other plant that
cost starts going up exponentially
are there other solutions here to
potentially breed plants to make those
other concentrations in higher
quantities absolutely but not to get
technical with you but plant biology is
pretty gross
it's very very difficult to get to work
and actually THC is a great example of
that in cannabis people have been
breeding and genetically modifying
cannabis for 30 years to get it THC
concentrations higher and I think the
largest I've seen as far as THC
percentage of total cannabinoid is in
kind of the 30 to 35 percent range so
thinking about doing that for all 100
bioactive molecules would be a really
really long time and again this is just
one of the variables so what economics
look like for our technology well for
cellular AG if you're using traditional
organisms and what I mean by traditional
organisms is if you look up the science
at all or you talk to anybody that's
doing it they're probably using one of
two critters they're using either a coli
or yeast and specifically baker's yeast
or what's known as sacrum I see Sarah
the CI the reason for that is anybody
with a masters or PhD has used those
cells pretty much their entire career
from academia academia to Pharma to
industrial applications etc they use
those organisms for good reasons they
have very very good qualities they grow
very very fast and and maybe more
importantly we understand them we know
their genetics we know how they act in
fermentation we know how to manipulate
them so Libra takes a fundamentally
different approach and it's an approach
that is really applicable here for
cannabinoids and that is we use non
traditional organisms and the reason
that we do that is instead of trying to
take in coline yeast and bang those
square pegs into a round hole to get
them to produce the product from care
about we say where is there a cell in
nature that's industrialized below where
we're closer to the endpoint
so we're using yeast as an example for
cannabinoid production might be like
using a Ford f-150 factory for producing
iPhones could you do it yep but you're
probably gonna have to switch out a lot
of machines and rewrite a lot of code
and do a lot of retrofitting and
eventually you'll get there and it'll
work what we do it's the Libra is we
kind of flipped that whole paradigm on
its head and we say well what if we
could find something that's closer to
the end what if we could find that
Samsung Galaxy Factory that has a lot of
the components and infrastructure that
we already need to make our iPhones and
we're just making small tweaks on the
edge our approach has some disadvantages
the disadvantages are not many people
understand these organisms so actually
scaling them isn't as straightforward as
it would be with eastery coli and in
addition working in them isn't the same
as yeast in e.coli the hammer that works
in East does not work in some of the
cells that we're talking about the way I
kind of the analogy I use and you'll see
me use a lot of car analogies I
apologize for that is it's kind of like
if you're using yeast you're working on
the Ford cars if you're working in some
of our organisms you're working in a
Bugatti it's a very very special skill
set where only a handful of people on
the planet quite frankly know how to
operate it and know how to work on those
cars better to be lucky than good we
have a scientific team that's been doing
this for decades and really understands
the organisms that we're going to be
working in as a result of using those
organisms we have some pretty distinct
advantages one is on the IP from but the
other one is just on the economics and
the quality that you'll get on the
product that you care about at the end
when you're trying to manipulate a cell
you have to remember that a cell while
I'm telling you it's a manufacturing
facility is not that simple it's a
living organism and those living
organisms have have evolved over
millions of years to do specific
functions and when cells are living
organisms evolved to do functions they
do so for survival so changing those
functions can be problematic nature
tends to when you change it come back
and try and kick in the hind end so
those are all things that you have to
consider when you're picking your
ultimate organism and the fact that
we're picking organisms that already
have the chemistry and biology that we
care about to make cannabinoids
means we have to make less changes to
those organisms who have evolved over
millions of years so that it provides us
a time advantage and also the risks the
the the project in the program quite a
bit the next one is consistency and I
want to thank Mark Lewis and the team at
Knapp row for sharing this data with me
you'll hear a lot of people in cannabis
say well we have the best genetics and
our genetics allow us to keep this plant
consistent and we can make it consistent
product time and time again that's not
necessarily true
genetics make up a very very small
portion I would say probably 10 to 30%
of what your ultimate chemical
composition is within that flower much
more important is your environmental
impact so things like what is your heat
what is your temperature what is your
humidity etc etc etc by the way that's
the reason that you see such high energy
use in the cannabis industries it's
really trying to control for that
environment but let me give you one
example that none of that we'll be able
to control for you've probably heard a
lot about the human microbiome that is
your stomach and all the gut bacteria
that you have in your stomach and how
that impacts your health
things like probiotics etc etc well
believe it or not plants are no
different we actually worked for a long
time with a small egg company called
Monsanto and they did a lot of great
research around the plant microbiome so
in the roots of the plant in the soil
there are actually big collections of
microbes that are known as the plant
microbiome and that microbiome actually
affects that plant quite significantly
from growth properties to composition
etc etc etc I don't know anybody in the
cannabis industry that its scale is
trying to control the plant microbiome
and I think when you're dealing with
products that have psychoactive or
potentially efficacy efficacy
implications consistency is really
really important and controlling a plant
is going to be difficult and this graph
here from our from a from Markin team
actually highlights that pretty well
what they did was they took a an OG kush
plant with the same jima genotype and
over various batch
they took that same genetics that same
plant and grew it under a variety of
conditions organic growth conditions
with the biostimulant just organic with
no stimulate and kind of conventional
methodologies using the stimulant and
what you see here is the percent weight
of the cannabinoid concentration varies
pretty significantly and then even
within that cannabinoid concentration
you have variations in which
cannabinoids make up those percentages
and this is just one example in one
facility of one genotype so when you see
products out in the marketplace that are
labeled as instant for instance OG Kush
or Girl Scout cookies all of those
different strains even though they're
named the same thing and they have that
same genetics you're not actually
consuming the same product and this
highlights one of the issues with with
consistency when you're using our
technology which you end up with is a
pure cannabinoid isolate so all we are
producing is one cannabinoid at a time
and this production is controlled and
that its fermentation it's GMP and it's
scaleable like a bunch of pharmaceutical
medicines are made today about 50% of
the world's medicines are using this
type of technology and what we are able
to do is not only produce the major
cannabinoids like CBD or or THC but we
unlock all 100 bioactive ingredients we
can make every single one of them at the
same cost at the same scale at the same
purity and this does a couple of things
one it unlocks all of those molecules
for study but two it also allows you to
do true formulations at scale so let's
go back to an example of an OG Kush
genetic strain that we do an extract
from and you want an extract that makes
up the same exact concentrations of that
what we will be able to do is actually
take all 100 cannabinoids plus the
terpenes and formulate those into a
concentration where they're the exact
same and make that product the same way
time after time year after year in in
product after product so it really does
truly provide a scalable consistency
across a variety of different areas all
of these factors kind of have different
weights depending on your ultimate use
case so there are a couple different
areas where cannabinoids and cannabis
extracts can be used the first is the
regulated therapeutics market the leader
here is a company called GW Pharma
that's both out of the UK and out of the
San Diego area they got the first
fda-approved natural product cannabis
product through the FDA here recently
and when you're talking about human
therapeutics where you've actually taken
something through the FDA for a specific
indication and you've done those
clinical trials cost becomes actually
much less important they're able to
charge a premium for these products
ultimately what does matter is
scalability to a point I try to use GW
Pharma here if it's a smaller condition
obviously scalability doesn't matter if
it's a large condition where there are a
lot of addressable of the addressable
market it's big because the patient
population is big scalability obviously
becomes more important but what is
ultimately the most important in the
pharmaceutical realm is this this idea
of consistency can I have the same
product every single time because we're
dealing potentially with
life-threatening diseases here and these
are being used as treatments for those
so having a consistent product that we
know we can take is really really
important the next market that we can
sell into is our cute little cats and
dogs and animal health and kind of
consumer consumer animal products
believe it or not there are some
cannabinoids here that are very very
interesting if you think about what the
plan is that's one big anti-inflammatory
so we've been in discussions with
multiple animal health companies about
for instance helping to treat cats and
dogs that have inflammation issues or
arthritis issues with certain
cannabinoid formulations cost a little
bit more important here people aren't
don't tend to spend as much money on the
dog and cat as they do on the kids but
still they will spend money so classes
and is it the utmost important
scalability isn't too too important here
either these markets aren't as big as
human therapeutic markets and Newman
consumer markets but again that will
depend on the indication but again just
like you
therapeutic consistency is going to be
important here now give you one great
example there are some cannabinoids that
some species of animal just don't
metabolize properly meaning once they
consume them they actually become become
toxic to those animals so if you are
using a cannabis extract product today
you should be very very sure that what
you're giving them is in fact what is on
the label number one and number two you
should really understand your sources
because it could be detrimental to your
little to your little critters next in
animal health there's also the consumer
animal health market we've been talking
to some of the pet food manufacturers
about potentially cannabinoid
formulations into pet food here these
are more commodity industries so your
cost is going to be much much more
important so you know going from tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
kilogram down to for us we think
ultimately sub 500 dollars a kilogram
for these ingredients will be important
these are also much bigger markets your
your dogs eat a lot more food than they
do take medicine so scalability is
important consistency not as important
here but again it's still the purity
piece of it is important but the
consistency of the product isn't isn't
necessarily as critical as it is in
those other two areas which is why we
labeled it as such and then the last
area of cannabis which is the one that
everybody thinks of is these these
consumer markets that have been coming
on online in Canada and in some states
here domestically in the u.s. here cost
these critical you are not going to be
able to make formulations with specific
cannabinoids for hundreds of thousands
of dollars into into a consumer market
even CBD products are probably too
expensive to get widespread adoption
today these markets are massive we
actually met with one of the three
largest beer producers in the world and
sat down with their scientific
leadership and we did so in one of their
facilities that makes over five hundred
cans of beer a day so when you're
thinking about that kind of scale
consistent let's the in scalability are
ultra critical and again when you're
dealing with human consumption of
anything consistency is always going to
be very very important maybe not as
important as when you're dealing with
life-threatening conditions but but
still very very important nonetheless so
that's why all of these things are very
critical all the all of the kind of
check
the boxes on our technology and why we
found that this was just a perfect
application of this science and given
all of the uses of these cannabinoids
and all of the good that they can do for
medicine and consumer products more
broadly we're very excited to kind of
unlock the the currently trapped
potential of the plant and the medicines
that the plant makes so with that I will
end the discussion a pretty picture of
me with my email address there look
forward to answering any questions that
you have and thank you so much for the
time today thank you mr. Sher Ali for
that informative presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go once let everyone know that
this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through june of 2019
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you
submitted being that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye